(upbeat music)
- Is there a way, is there
a process or something
that you do to yourself
to raise your awareness,
to see new things, so that
you can always kind of
be on track or even be ahead
of where you want to go?
- For me, developing
self-awareness starts with
figuring out your one-word,
we talked about this,
I think for another video,
but I believe everybody
has one word that kind of defines them
and you need to understand what that is
so your constantly
living your true values.
So for me, it's believe, you
know, you've got got inspire.
As you look at your work,
as you look at your life,
it now becomes, like if
that's who you truly are,
if you're really about inspire,
and then you look at your videos,
and you look at your marriage,
and you look at your kids,
and you look at your house,
and you look at everything it applies to.
It's the most important
core value for you.
- It's like your essence.
- Yeah, it's the lens to the world,
and I'm believe, you're
inspire, like it's close
but we're not the same either, right?
Somebody else who picks
inspire, your inspire would
be a little different than
theirs, but at least you know,
and you're always going to be unhappy
in a situation where
there's no inspiration.
If your marriage doesn't
have any more inspiration,
you're going to be upset, it's
going to lead to unhappiness.
If your work is boring,
you're going to feel boxed in,
there's no inspiration,
you're going to be upset,
you're going to have to
find a change, right?
And so a lot of people
don't know what their,
they just feel the angst
without having a solution.
So understanding what your one-word is
is a great start so that you can say,
okay you know what I don't
have enough inspire my life,
I don't have enough believe my life.
I got to go find a way
to inject some of that,
so you start feel good
again, through your business,
to your career, to your
marriage, all of that stuff.
That's the starting point.
I think then it's overcoming
the fear to go out and do it.
I think building the muscles is important,
I think the best way to do it
is through your environment.
I think a lot of people
would be in the situation
where they are like,
great, I'm about inspire.
I have my own business and I
love it, inspire, great, okay.
I'm going to go off and
today's the day now.
Here are all the ten ways I'm
going to inject some inspire in.
You are on fire, like finally,
yeah, I've got life into me,
like, who's this new person?
And then it all falls apart.
Like the next day you're
up and what was that
I was smoking yesterday, it's gone.
Your back your crappy life, what happened?
Cause your life doesn't support it.
You have a big goal and your environment
doesn't match the goal, so
you fall right back down.
Like if you want to learn French,
the fastest way is to go to France,
like be emersed, you're
forced to learn it.
If you just try to pick it up
from an audiobook once a week,
like you're not going to, it's
not going to happen for you.
You've got to live it,
and your environment
needs to scream it, right?
- Well, how do you do that?
- Well, whatever it means to you,
like what is inspire, who was
most inspiring person to you?
If it's Albert Einstein,
if its Quentin Tarantino,
if it's, like whoever, I'm not judging.
- Surround yourself like on the walls?
- Like you love Che Guevara,
or whatever, right, like yeah.
I mean, we just went to the
store, the picture of the girl,
the girl that I couldn't catch,
you know, on my wall helps me.
I touched it, is it okay?
The picture on the wall helped me make
the hard decision in my life,
where normally I probably
would've backed down, but
because I saw that daily
I didn't want to live with regret again,
I reminded myself of the pain of not
asking that girl to
coffee, and that let me
make the most important
decision in my life.
And so you need to be
surrounded by inspire.
You to have it, it's your
physical environment, right?
What's on the wall, what's on the floor,
you can't live in a box, for
someone who loves inspire.
You can't live in a cookie-cutter box.
It's not inspiring, right?
You need to do something
funky with your space, right?
- So like your space has to
reflect your inner thoughts
or vice versa, you should
put things in your space
that affect your inner thoughts?
- Think about the big goal you have
when you have those moments of boldness,
like the ultimate Rich,
or the ultimate Jane,
or the ultimate Johnny, what
environment is he or she in?
What is this space scream?
And then maybe the
ultimate vision is, yes,
I'm in Maui and I've got like a balcony.
Okay, great, start with a
picture of Maui on the wall.
Like there's costs associated
with some of these things
you want to do, so start smaller, right?
I want to be around Steve
Jobs and his big thinking.
Okay, it's possible, he's dead,
I never met him and I never will.
But I can put his picture on the wall,
that might cost me 20
bucks or whatever it is
and that injects a little bit of Steve
into me everyday when I go in.
Physical space is important.
From there you look at
your habits, your routines,
the content that you read.
Are you reading books
that make you inspired,
or are you reading People
Magazine or whatever, right?
Like, not to get down on People Magazine,
but look at what content you're consuming
and does it help you become that person?
Now somebody who, somebody
whose word might be security,
maybe a box is perfect for them.
They don't want the chaos
of switching out light bulbs
and putting new carpets
and new stuff on the wall.
All that uncertainty
is not great for them,
they couldn't live in
that crazy environment.
Great, go live in the box, it's perfect.
But then you need to have
other things around security
that make you feel like you're in charge
of what you're doing.
So we've talked about
physical environment.
Look at the people in your life.
Do the people in your
life, are they inspiring?
Do the people that you talk to daily,
do they inspire you or do they just like,
can you tell them this
crazy idea that you have,
and they are like oh yeah
yeah yeah, okay great.
Or, even worse, like you can't do that,
you didn't go to school to do that, Rich.
Like, what are you, nuts?
How are you going to be a photographer?
You didn't go to school for that,
you don't have family connections there.
There's a thousand photographers,
what makes you so special?
Right, lie that's a lot of people,
like those are the people in their life.
That's not inspire, right?
So the people in your
life, the books you read,
the videos you watch, and
an easy way to kind of
figure that out is think about,
we've all had moments, like
you've had moments in your life
where you've been that best self,
you've had moments you've
been super inspired.
What was happening there?
Was it watching a Tony Robbins video?
Was it doing some adventurous
thing with your wife?
Was it reading to your
kids, whatever it is, right?
Like, not judging, whatever
it is you need to do.
Now instead of having it happen randomly
at 5 o'clock on a Monday afternoon,
because you happen to
turn on a Youtube channel,
build it into your routine.
- Pause it, schedule it.
- Yeah, with purpose, yeah,
start every day with this stuff,
whatever it is, great,
if you need to wake up,
scratch your back, run in
a circle for three-minute,
I don't care, if that's what
gets you to be that better.
I reset everyday, I great
now, you've got me pumped up,
we're spreading some love,
this is amazing, right?
I'm going to some other
interviews and stuff after today
and tomorrow morning to wake up and
- And it's back to scratch, huh?
- Yeah, I got to start over,
it's square one everyday.
And so I need to, I inject
believe into my life daily.
You need to.
- And you know, I think this
is where a lot of people
fall down is they think
because I'm inspired now,
that it's, that's my new way of being,
and when they wake up the
next morning or the next day
or the next week and
it's not there, like aw,
that didn't work, that sucks.
- It's gone, yeah.
This is likely going to be the
next, it's the next book man.
- That's why you have to like restart.
- The first books about
finding your one word,
the self awareness, and
the next one designing
that environment, because
that's what holds people back.
Your environment sucks,
maybe I'll call that,
that's the name of the book:
Your Environment Sucks.
- I think also, people's
expectation and thinking
that it's done, it's fixed,
and then when it's not,
they don't have that persistence
like as an entrepreneur,
you really have to persist.
You're going to fail now, you're
going to fail again and again
and you've got to keep persisting.
A lot of people think I tried
once, maybe I tried twice,
but it didn't work out
and that's it, I'm done,
I'm going back to my
old ways, when really,
they have to be present
and that it's an everyday,
moment to moment thing.
- Yeah, I mean, I think the only way
that works is if you enjoy the work.
If we're talking about
entrepreneurship now,
like most entrepreneurs fail,
I think the big reason is people look up,
they pull out a magazine of
the top hundred businesses
to start in 2017, like,
notes the number one,
photography, great, I'm going
to be a photographer in 2017.
And then they're going to go
up against people like you,
you who have a passion
for what you're doing
and it's art form and you've
injected your personality
and creativity and you're
going to crush them.
And they're going to try,
and it's going to be hard,
and they're going to quit.
If you're only chasing the end goal,
you're never going to get there.
- You got to check with yourself when,
I know with you, you talked about before,
it's really, you don't talk about it now,
but it's really a feeling
kind of thing with you,
like if you feel good about it,
if you love it, if you
enjoy it, you do it.
As soon as you don't want to do it,
you won't force yourself, which
is kind of counter-intuitive
or not counter-intuitive,
but it's counter to the ways
everything's run in society.
You have to go to work at 8 or 9,
you just have to go to school,
and you just have to do this
and you have to do that.
- Yeah.
- And you do it whether
you like it or not.
But with you, it's backwards, isn't it?
You only do it if you
really want to do it.
Can you talk about that?
- Yeah, the more, you know
everybody has a bad days
and it's all gravy and amazing
and even in my life too,
I have bad days, but if I find myself
doing the same thing repeatedly
and I like it less and
less less less less like,
I got it, like this has to be cut somehow.
If it is important to the business,
then I'm going to hire someone to do it.
If it's not important to
the business and it's out,
I'm going to do something else.
We did a top ten on
Jerry Seinfeld recently,
and one of the things he was talking about
was doing the work that
other people find torture,
the torture that you enjoy.
So people look at my schedule,
within a Youtube context,
I'm filming, we film at least three videos
a day go up on the Youtube channel.
Where a lot of people have a hard time
making a video a week,
we're doing three a day.
People look at my schedule
and say that's insane,
it's torture, who'd would
want to do that, right?
And I would look at yours and
say Rich, you're nuts man.
I don't want to sit there and edit video,
that's torture man.
You put me in your job, I would pick up
a smoking habit or something.
It's torture, I would hate it, right?
But for you it's love.
For me, I love doing it.
This is not work for me.
For a lot of people, they'd be like
oh I've got to do this stupid
interview, you know whatever,
they hate it, right?
It won't be a great interview.
I love this, I got get
jazzed up from this, right?
I'm leaving this on a high, right?
I love it and so too many
people are just addicted
to the outcome, where you
have to enjoy the process.
You've got to enjoy the work,
so if I do it doesn't work,
okay, keep doing it, you do it to do it,
you do it because you love doing it
and you'll figure out
a way to make it work,
not just chasing the
work and then whatever
I have to do that to make it work, right?
You'll never get there.
The people who've had success in any field
entrepreneurship or
career, anything, they love
the business, they love
getting up and doing the work.
They may not love every
day or every part of it,
it's not all roses, but they like the work
and when other people
looking their schedule
it looks like torture.
(dramatic music)